hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work on anger
particularly in chapters six through
nine Seneca considers some objections
that a person might make to his position
on anger as a snowic he thinks that
anger really has no productive or
positive role in moral life and stoics
were all about valuing virtue and wisdom
wisdom as one of the virtues but wisdom
is also what guides the virtues they
hold out the Exemplar of the wise person
or sage and so some people might say
well you know The Virtuous person
ought to get angry when they see people
doing the wrong thing and the wise
person actually can tell what is good
and bad and therefore should be you know
happy to see the The Good Deeds of good
people and likewise should be angry at
the wicked Deeds of the bad or evil so
the question here is shouldn't virtue
and wisdom involve the response of anger
at various forms of Badness and it'll
actually in you know some of these
chapters give a lot of examples about
how bad people can be so you know he
sees this as sort of a correlative it's
expressed this way just as virtue is
kindly disposed to honorable good
behavior Noble Behavior so should a
great disgraceful Behavior with anger
and seneca's first response to this is
what if one should say that virtue ought
to be both abject humilus and
magnificent Magnus that is exactly what
is meant when one wishes anger to be
raised up and debased so he's saying
there's a bit of a contradiction there
in the way that you're thinking about
this but then he gives a let's say much
better argument based on analysis of our
emotional states and again this is uh
presuming some stoic psychology of the
emotions you could say so he talks about
gladness uh and uses two different words
in these paragraphs lytitia which we
often translate as joy as well and
gaudium these are both positive affects
towards things we have gladness which is
derived from right action latitia
um
seeing the good things the right things
the upright things being done by people
you feel good about that right you see
somebody doing something good that is
your positive response you can also be
glad about your own right action as well
so that makes perfect sense right and he
says that this is Splendid and
magnificent but
anger caused by another's wrongdoing
right so responding uh to other people's
wrongdoing with anger is as he says mean
sordida the word that we get sorted from
like in a low class and stuff like that
and he talks about a pinched spirit is
one way to translate it right of of our
mind we could say narrow-mindedness is
another way of translating it as well so
anger is not really going to be becoming
of virtue right he says that
um
you know it's a natural property of
virtue to be glad and joyful being angry
is no more in accord with virtues
standing than is grief and then he says
something very very interesting
particularly if we're thinking about the
history of the emotions Seneca is one of
the really people to make this
connection he tells us that wrath has
sadness as its companion and it
inevitably turns to sadness either after
it comes to feel regret or after it's
rebuffed so anger or
wrathundia he uses both of these terms
here in this has sadness tristia as its
companion and other later authors
particularly in the Christian era will
note the connection between era anger
wrath and tristia sadness depression
sorrow however we want to translate it
so these are some very interesting
points that he's making about the way
our emotions work and which ones are
good to have and which ones are not good
to have he also says something else
that's very important with respect to
virtue
he tells us that virtue will never make
the mistake of imitating vices while
seeking to check them it holds that
anger as such must be reprimanded right
it anger is to be dealt with
productively which means oftentimes not
getting angry or criticizing the anger
right so it doesn't make sense for
virtue to as we often say Fight Fire
with Fire it ceases to be virtue by
doing so and here we see a common trap
that many people fall into they assume
that because they're kind of virtuous or
on the way to Virtue they can engage in
things that actually go against virtue
because that's the right thing to do
which then leads to Vice that vitiates
their virtue that was developing so
that's the discussions of virtue as such
then he turns to talking about the wise
person and and here he has a whole bunch
of what we call counter factuals he's
making arguments making cases to say no
no we shouldn't fall into this this is
not what the wise person
ought to be like so what does he say he
tells us that if being angry at
wrongdoing is proper for a wise man he
doesn't think that's the case right then
the greater the wrongdoings the greater
the anger is going to be and he will be
angry often if follows he says the wise
person will not only experience anger
they will not only feel anger they will
be wrathful by disposition they will be
iroquundas
if they're actually wise they're going
to see many more cases of people that
will anger them right
he goes and he says we believe that
neither great nor frequent anger has a
place in the wise man's Soul right and
he says a limit on anger cannot exist if
anger must be felt in proportion to each
person's Behavior
either you will be unjust if you feel
the same degree of anger for different
degrees of wrongdoing if you play
favorites or for example if you were to
feel angry at one person doing the wrong
thing act discharge your anger and then
not get as angry with the next person
doing the same thing if you're going to
be wise if you're going to be just both
of which are virtues for the stoics then
you need to be angry in proportion to
the wrongdoing you need to treat people
the way that they Merit or deserve to be
treated as he says you're going to be
angry in the extreme if you feel angers
full heat as often as misdeeds Merit
wrath right so this is going to be a big
trap and he's suggesting all this to say
that's not the way the wise person is
going to be and then he gives this sort
of a general principle that's quite
important here it's unworthy indignous
is the the Latin term for a wise
person's passion odd factors they're
affect their overall uh you know
emotional state to be determined by
another person's wickedness this makes
the wise person no longer free no longer
self-determining no longer autonomous we
might say to use a later vocabulary
because they're just responding to
everything going on around them you
could imagine them as the ordinary
person maybe has 20 buttons the wise
person has an Infinity of buttons that
can be pushed right this is not a wise
way of being or a virtuous way of being
it doesn't make sense he says he goes
out and he says well the great Socrates
no longer be able to return home wearing
the same expression he had when he left
meaning that he walks out the door
enters the marketplace meets a bunch of
jerks Seneca is going to go on and
detail this if the wise person should be
angry at shameful behavior and be riled
and gloomy because of criminal Behavior
he must be the most troubled man in the
world he'll pass his entire life in
anger and grief will there be an instant
when he'll Nazi thing is worthy of
reproach whenever he leaves his home
he'll have to make his way through
crowds of criminal and people who are
greedy spendthrift Shameless and
prosperous because of these very vices
so we'll see bad people not only doing
bad things but doing well in their eyes
at least you know in terms of property
or reputation or Pleasures because of
the Iran doing and so if wisdom consists
in getting ticked off at that sort of
stuff we're going to be angrier the
wiser we are and that doesn't really
make sense and so he gives a a bunch of
examples we don't need to actually go
through all of these and we can skip
ahead a little bit I mean he says why go
through individual cases and then he
goes through a whole bunch of other
General examples as well the the key
idea here
he says the wise person will never cease
to be angry once he begins if we follow
this mistaken line of reasoning why
there is a full load of crimes and vices
everywhere more crime is committed than
punishment can remedy right we're
engaged in a struggle a vast struggle
with wickedness and now here Seneca
engages in a little bit of pessimistic
ooh things are worse now than they were
before and then perhaps they they are
depending on how we look at it I mean a
lot of Roman history is pretty full of
crimes and vices uh but seneca's time
and he's living in the time of Nero so
yeah maybe there's something to that and
we can think about our own time if it's
radically different than this he says
the desire to do wrong is greater every
day the sense of modest restraint is
diminished regard for what is better and
more just has been cast out lust imposes
Itself by force wherever it wishes is
nor our crimes now kept secret they go
on right before our eyes wickedness has
been so broadcast and gained such power
in everyone's breast innocence is not
rare it's non-existent
further surely the law Breakers aren't
isolated individuals or a mere handful
are they no they've Arisen on every side
as though a signal had been given and
then he says that what's been confounded
here is right and wrong people have lost
their moral bearings they you can't even
say that they have a moral compass
they don't even have a little bit of a
moral compass right so now if you're a
wise person how should you treat this it
doesn't mean that you have to pretend
that everything is A-Okay that Justice
is still there you know even in
Injustice you don't have to be
unrealistically optimistic about things
but you don't also have to allow the
injustices the wrongdoing to lead you
into the response of anger in seneca's
view because that would actually be
allowing those things to determine you
rather than being self-determining
rather than sticking to your own
sources of potential joy and happiness
so neither the wise nor The Virtuous
person which I actually are the same
person are going to be
radically dependent upon the world of
others and what wrongdoing is going to
take place they will be able to live a
happy life even in the middle of bad
people
precisely because they're not going to
allow anger and the small-mindedness the
pinched spirit
that you know is represented in that to
determine their state of mind so this is
how Seneca deals with these potential
objections about The Virtuous and wise
person and whether or not they should
feel anger or not